استمرار العمليه العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال
في مخيم نور شمس في مدينه طول كرم وسط
تعزيزات عسكريه اسرائيليه لا تزال متواصله
تصل تباعا الى هذه المنطقه نرصد هنا في
هذه الصوره حيث تواجد لعشرات الاليات
العسكريه في هذه اللحظات هنا في المنطقه
وسط حراك مستمر لاليات الاحتلال العسكريه
التي لا تزال تصل تباعا حتى هذه اللحظه ما
يزيد
عن 40 اليه عسكريه وصلت الى هذه المنطقه
كما تشاهدون في هذه الصوره في هذه اللحظات
ل اتصال او تواصل الاليات العسكريه التي
لا تزال تصل الى الحي الشمالي من المدينه
ووسط يعني حاله من الصخب واصوات التي
يطلقها الاحتلال في هذه اللحظات
الاشتباكات لا تزال متواصله حتى هذه
اللحظه في مخيم نور شمس اقتحامات لبعض
اطراف مخيم طول كرم ومرورا الى مخيم نور
شمس وسط تفجير لعشرات العبوات الناسفه
التي لا تزال تسمع هذه القوه كانت متواجده
في منطقه شويكا الى الشمال من المدينه ثم
انسحبت على ما يبدو باتجاه بوابه 104 او
ما تسمى بتسني عوز الى الغرب من المدينه و
بعد ان قامت ب يعني اجراء عمليات ازعاج
واسعه في المدينه واطلاق للقنابل
الصوتيه الانفجارات لا تزال متواصله
والعمليه العسكريه لا تزال حتى هذه اللحظه
متواصله في المدينه لقناه الجزيره ليث
جعار طول كرم